look uh and I want to thank a good
friend of mine Michigan governor
Gretchen Whitmer you've got a backbone
like a ramrod you know and of course
I know you've had an incredible role
model in America Lance bottoms she's got
a backbone like a ramrod the vice
president of the United States Vice
President Harris how's she doing you're
almost two years in she's doing great
she has a backbone like a ramrod but the
truth is she's the strongest person I
know she's a backbone like a ramrod I
see the world where I grew up like many
of you I grew up in Scranton as I said
my mom taught me
my mom had a backbone like a ramrod
Dave Rubin this is the Reuben report
it's uh October 24 2022 where live
streaming on Rumble YouTube and Blaze TV
and I gotta tell you people
I've got a backbone like a ramrod
whatever the high hell that means and so
do you if you're watching this show
what is going on here what is going on I
hope you had a great weekend uh we had a
great weekend around here I smoked a 12
pound brisket I still smell like meat
that was that's what's going on here I
got a backbone like a ramrod I smell
like smoked brisket and we're gonna talk
about politics because the question is
as we now are getting very very closely
I'm crying I'm laughing so much uh the
question is as we're getting close to
this election
will the Democrat policy work will the
policy of crashing the economy getting
us to war and chopping off everyone's
penises work it's a you know they focus
group this they thought it was going to
work and the question is will it work
that's what we're going to be tackling
today uh but for real like joking aside
for a second I mean the Democrats are in
a lot of trouble like there's a lot of
good news if you are sane if you like
America if you like freedom and the
Constitution and you remember something
that was better than this lunacy we're
in right now well then there is a lot of
good news if you're a Democrat there
isn't good news uh that being said with
about 10 days left or whatever it is uh
you know they could go hot with Ukraine
covid9 you guys know all the uh all the
nonsense but the Democrats really are in
a lot of trouble and the question will
be how will they recalibrate over these
10 days to scare people and everything
else so that's what we're talking about
today and man I had a backbone like a
ram Rod wasn't that one of Jordan
Peterson's 12 rules stand up straight
and get a backbone like a ramrod
something like that all right before we
get to it let's talk about Patriot
mobile uh you know I recently did a show
on woke corporations and their Origins
uh thankfully conservatives are creating
a parallel economy that is thriving and
I want to tell you about a new sponsor
that's making a real difference Patriot
mobile has exploded over the last year
they're proud conservatives offering a
real alternative for people tired of
funding major cell phone carriers who've
all gone woke left Patriot mobile is a
force for conservative values this is
because they take a portion of your bill
and they fund conservative causes and
candidates people who believe in the
sanctity of Life freedom of speech the
Second Amendment and they're winning in
fact their pack Patriot mobile action
flipped 11 School Board races across
Texas recently Patriot mobile has
affordable plans for you your family and
even your business they offer the same
Nationwide coverage as the major
carriers because they use multiple major
networks so you get the same great
service minus is the leftist propaganda
go to patriotmobile.com Reuben or call
972 Patriot get free activation when you
use the special offer code Reuben
special discounts are also available for
veterans and First Responders make the
switch today and a difference tomorrow
patriotmobile.com Reuben that's patreon
mobile.com Reuben or call 972 Patriot
and now back to me all right ramrod here
we go uh all right so look everybody
realizes this thing is looking like a
bloodbath for the Democrats and it
should that is the key to all of this uh
what is happening right now is what
should happen it is how we are going to
reverse this and as I said the other day
we will be able to look in the rear view
mirror and go AO see you later we will
put this wokeness behind us this endless
Insanity behind us we can do it but as
we get closer to that like as you get
closer to the Finish Line it's going to
get crazier uh so this this for first
video that we're going to show you this
is Jake Tapper over at CNN as you guys
know Jake is he's a Democrat activist in
essence right if you asked him what he
really is uh if he was you know on a lie
detector test you would have to say he's
a Democrat it's obvious he's Run cover
for democrats for a long time but and
and by the way he's not even close to
the worst at CNN you know he's thought
of as the moderate it's CNN uh anyway uh
he had old socialist and sort of
irrelevant voice Bernie Sanders that one
kind of petered out quick on the show
over the weekend uh to discuss why it is
that things are looking so bad under
Democrat control and Bernie's response
is quite curious to play devil's
advocate here if I'm a swing voter out
there a young voter a working-class
voter I and I hear your message I think
but you guys control everything
Democrats control the house and the
Senate and the White House and inflation
is really high and I'm having a deaf
tough time making ends meet why should I
vote for you again
well we have half the votes exactly half
the votes in the Senate and the tiny
majority uh in the house and I think
it's important that when we talk about
inflation Republicans will say well this
is Joe Biden's fault really
our inflation rate is much too high it
is eight percent it is 10 in the UK 10
throughout Europe seven percent in
Canada inflation is a global problem
caused a by the breaking of Supply
chains because of the pandemic by the
war in Ukraine and as I said significant
part of inflation has to do with
corporate greed
oh yeah you knew he was going to throw
that in at the end it's the corporations
guys it's the people that are producing
things it's their fault they've just
decided they're not in the mood to
produce as much stuff for you they're
the ones it's like you know West Elm and
CB2 and Best Buy they're really behind
why you it takes so long to get a couch
and a TV they just decided they didn't
want you to get that 75-inch flat screen
and that cushy new couch and the rest of
it uh no no that's actually not right uh
Bernie also he completely obfuscated the
beginning of this yes it is true the
Democrats are in control of everything
he says the Senate has a tie yes but
they have the vice president who is the
tiebreaker so the Senate is to the
Democrats that's number one number two
uh he then says well we have a slim
majority in the house well all right a
slim majority can still operate the same
way a big majority can uh and uh and
then he Compares us to a whole bunch of
other countries uh which is interesting
saying that they are worse than us but
he's usually telling us how great those
countries are and how bad America is so
this is a very very bizarre thing and
then of course blaming uh corporations
the reason I even played that clip is
because it's interesting how irrelevant
Bernie feels now right and that was
always how it was going to end with
Bernie Bernie was always going to end as
the old irrelevant white millionaire
socialist who was just going to be
yammering on and looking crazier and
crazier as he doesn't get haircuts and
and that would be the end of Bernie
Sanders so I think we're almost at the
end of Bernie Sanders his legacy well
that he he is the one who ushered in a
lot of this socialist nonsense so I
guess he can put that on a little little
plaque when he retires in one of his
three houses but the point there is no
one's buying this nonsense no one's
blaming the corporations for inflation
inflation has to do with say the
inflation reduction Act and the endless
printing of money and giving all the
money to Ukraine and all of those things
no one's buying the Democrat line on
this and it's coming out in the polls
and even the corporate propagandist over
in MSNBC they can't hide it msnb AC and
NBC here's Chuck Todd with some new
polling data digging deeper here we've
got some all-time midterm highs that
should serve as red flags for the
Democrats the wrong track 71 percent
all-time midterm High since we've been
polling how about presidential approved
disapproval on the economy sitting at 57
percent again we hadn't recorded that uh
ever that high in our poll and the third
one the direction of the economy and the
next Shares are going to get better or
worse 50 percent say it's going to get
worse again an all-time high in mid-term
polling okay so I want to focus on the
first number he read out there which was
71 polled say we're on the wrong track
now you guys again you know my feelings
about polls and I think this often Bears
out after elections they end up being
wildly off or they'll tell you this
person this group of people were
misrepresented or a certain amount of
these people don't pick up their phones
or whatever it might be so you have to
take a sum of this with a grain of salt
but the trends are getting so addict
control now and they're becoming and the
gaps are so obvious that there really is
something going on here might I also
recommend you know just talk to your
friends and family are our people even
even left-leaning people even Democrats
are they going boy things aren't really
going well right now it feels like
Biden's on the ball and we're safe and
they're we're not going to nuclear war
and Armageddon and you know all of the
stuff
so if you don't want to just trust polls
go to that but the number that I want to
focus on is that 71 percent say we're on
the wrong track that strikes me as a
really really crazy number we were told
that Joe Biden got 81 million votes old
Joe Biden who didn't do any rallies who
you couldn't find anyone that really
supported him except the media loved him
and you know sort of big Tech loved him
and they had to take out orange man 81
million people voted for this guy and
now 71 of people polled are saying the
country's going in the wrong direction
that that the bottom is falling out I
think that is the phrase one might use
on that this guy is in a lot of trouble
and everyone sees it he is the
sacrificial lamb and they will take him
out one way or another after the
midterms that is obvious he's dead man
walking I don't know if he can see it or
not because he's so muddled we'll get uh
we'll get to more on that in just a
minute but the Democrats are in a lot of
trouble and the numbers bear it out
right the numbers abs absolutely bear it
out on cbs's Face the Nation this
weekend they talked to Chicago Democrat
voters and they discussed well what's
going on with the Democrats because you
know in Chicago we'll find out how many
people got shot in Chicago this weekend
can we do that while we throw to this
clip uh so here is video of this is just
a random woman they went to find
Democrats in Chicago her name is lashon
uh and uh she's not happy with Democrats
in Chicago Sean I'd like to get you to
weigh in on this I can also agree with
some of his points
um I really would say sex education I
feel like um some things you know are
brought to the children's attention they
wouldn't even think about and you have
eight kids I imagine you have some
pretty specific ideas in your mind when
you're speaking yes about this yes and
so choosing our yeah they're really
influenced you can teach them one thing
at home but when they go to school
they're just as much influenced by their
teachers and their surroundings and we
should have more input to parents of
what we want them to learn
Now isn't that fascinating isn't that
fascinating just wait till Daily Beast
or huffpo or Media Matters or somebody
tries to do a hit piece on lashon a
mother of eight in Chicago who's upset
that they're teaching all this gender
craziness to her kids right she's by any
estimation I would guess this woman is
basically a lefty a Democrat right she
lives in a big city in Chicago she just
doesn't want her kids being infected
with this stuff at the public school
level but that is not what the Democrats
want people saying right so now she's
going to have to be a bad person that is
how it works we did a little research
while we were throwing a bat clip what'd
you tell me 54 shot 55 sorry
55 people were shot in Chicago this
weekend 11 were killed in Chicago this
weekend Chicago Illinois which has one
of the strongest gun laws in the country
I mean that is abs absolutely insane
there will be no protests there will be
no riots you won't find out any of their
names because basically all 55 people
shot were black all 11 people killed
were black and the shooters were black
thus the media doesn't know what to do
with this if you want a little more
context on the numbers
448 shot and killed from January 1st
2022 to September 1st 2022 okay so
that's in nine months which of course is
a record uh let's continue though
because what else are the Democrats
running on well they're running on this
radical policy on abortion right they
could say they could try to be moderate
on something they could say hey we
really want to protect a woman's right
we don't want you know the government
making decisions how about three months
that used to be the decent Democrat
position it is now the Republican
position right 15 weeks here in Florida
that is the moderate position here's Amy
Klobuchar uh from Minnesota as you know
and she was on The View discussing
polling data related to abortion I have
seen these polls go Every Which Way but
what I do know
or now
people don't know
freedom to vote
freedom to have our democracy freedom to
be able to make your own reproductive
Health Care decisions without having Ted
Cruz sitting in the waiting room okay
oh God it's so boring it's so boring and
not thoughtful and weak first off lady
is up why do all the Democrats end up
looking crazy they all end up they get
crazy with the facelifts and the Botox
and the Restylane or whatever they're
doing but she's what did she do to her
eyes what did she do to her eyes she
looks nuts okay so yes Ted Cruz does not
want to be in the waiting room it's just
it's just a silly nonsensical joke but
what's interesting about this is I when
when this whole thing happened with the
reversal of Roe v Wade and the the
papers that were leaked right the
Supreme Court decision that was leaked
early and by the way we never found out
who did that does that seem a little odd
that we just completely moved past that
a massive extraordinary assault a data
breach on one of the branches of
government we just never figured it out
but okay putting that aside everyone
kept saying oh if they reverse Roe v
Wade and just kick it back to the States
again abortion is not legal you guys
know that not illegal it is up to the
States now which is exactly how it was
before 1972 I think it was um the whole
idea was hey this is going to help the
Democrats because you're going to enrage
women to the point that we'll see it in
the polls and women will come out and
it's actually the reverse believe it or
not it is the reverse and there is a lot
of polling data on that so real clear
politics
uh has been pulled they've been polling
forever basically uh but they are now
showing that uh the the largest lead for
Republicans uh is right now it's the
biggest lead that they've had since
before the Dobbs versus Jackson decision
I think we've got some info for you here
so this is the Senate battle this is
Real Clear Politics the Senate battle
they think that in about two weeks from
now once we get the results of the
election that the Senate will flip that
50 50 situation that we're in with the
tiebreaker to the Dems it will flip and
it will go red now look some of these
are not totally for sure right we don't
know what's going to happen with
Herschel Walker in uh impact in well we
don't know what's going to happen with
Dr Oz in Pennsylvania we don't know
what's going to happen with Herschel
Walker in Georgia Blake Masters in
Arizona so some of these are you know
these are all not perfect this is
everyone you know playing that
prediction game but real clear politics
which has a pretty solid track record uh
they are now saying 53 for the
Republicans 47 for the Democrats and
they're talking about some of the trends
that uh they're they're not just pulling
this out of thin air that Blake Masters
and dakaras and Herschel Walker are now
tightening their races and you want to
tighten right before election day
obviously so they think that all of
those seats will be flipped uh they also
think that Adam laxalt of Nevada is uh
going to get the the seed over there and
that he will flip that which will be
interesting if I'm not mistaken uh Adam
laxalt he was wasn't he Governor
DeSantis college roommate I think he was
governor DeSantis his college roommate I
met him at an event a couple weeks ago
seemed like a really nice guy obviously
I'm not I'm not perfectly versed in
everything that's going on in Nevada but
struck me as a decent guy and if
DeSantis likes him that's pretty much
good enough for me a little more from
real clear politics here so what they
predict will happen is at the end of
this there will be basically 175
Democrat seats 225 Republican seats and
then there's these 35 toss-ups so that's
that's really where the meat of this and
and what the end of it will look like
real clear politics projects that the
GOP is going to pick up 12 to 47 seats
and roughly 29 is sort of where they
think things are going to be at and then
we've got a little bit more on the
governor's side of things they are
predicting that by the end of election
night or the two or three days after
that because that's how it works these
days they expect 31 Republican Governors
and 19 Democrat Governors which is a net
plus three for the Republicans and the
ones that are interesting on there if
you're looking at the map right now can
we go back to the map for a second the
ones that are interesting on the map
right there Nevada Wisconsin and
Michigan so Whitmer they're saying
goodbye Gretchen Whitmer and I'll even
toss in one more I I really believe it
maybe I am a dreamer and sometimes
I'm going to get things wrong people
right like I thought Larry Elder had a
chance in corrupt California I got that
one wrong obviously but I'm telling you
there is I'm talking to a lot of people
in New York right now there is something
going on in New York you got to remember
nobody voted for Kathy hochel right she
was installed after they got rid of
Andrew Cuomo she has been horrible on
lockdowns horrible on the economy she
has told people in New York to leave if
they don't share her values and come to
Florida plenty of them are she New York
City is an absolute disaster I honestly
think New York could flip mark my words
and maybe I'll be wrong and then they
can clip this and make fun of me but I
really think it's possible but but
Michigan getting rid of Gretchen Whitmer
who didn't want people to plant their
Gardens during kovid and New York flip
and man that would be something of
course they do think the Carrie Lake
will win in Arizona and she's been
absolutely on fire DeSantis of course is
going to crush it here in Florida and
speaking of that I am going tonight
after the show today I gotta hop in the
car a couple hour drive I'm heading up
to the one gubernatorial debate that
they have here in Florida which will be
Governor DeSantis versus this this empty
suit he's this empty suit of a fake tan
the worst kind of politician flip-flops
on everything has no beliefs wanted
lockdowns awful human being used to be
pro-life now he wants eight-month
abortions Charlie Crist so I'm going to
that thing tonight so I'll see if I can
get some video maybe I can snag the
governor for a little bit uh anyway uh
it continues because now the press as
they're realizing that they can kind of
turn on Biden a little bit more because
the whole thing's falling apart so they
need that sacrificial lamb as I've said
they're starting to ask him some more
questions about uh polling and uh here's
Joe's answer to one of those such
questions
do you think States should have a right
to ban gender whole after poll shows
that the American the American people
trust Republicans on the economy and
think that Republicans should control
Congress how do you how first of all
that I'm not sure about the polls
because you know the way people conduct
polls a day it's hard 90 of us you get
on a telephone where you have to call
seven times to get somebody to to answer
the phone
all right I'll give you something there
I wanted to show you that one because uh
Joe doesn't really believe in polls they
they believe in polls when they work for
them they don't believe in polls when
they don't work for them uh that
interview continued it was it was an
absolute train wreck uh and Joe Biden
was asked about his age which the
implication really was his his cognitive
abilities
I think people should look and say is it
they still have the same
passion for what he's doing and if they
think I do and I can do it then that's
fine if they don't then they should vote
against me not Advanced me should
encourage me not to go but that's not
how I feel I can't even say the age I'm
going to be I can't even get it out of
my mouth ah it's so he's so creepy he
usually just touches young girls and
Snips their hair there he was moving on
that guy and touching him you can see
the way he backs up like why is this old
weirdo grabbing me he also muddles
through the sentence I mean he cannot
say one complete coherent sentence I
mean to be a dick but that's a problem
that is a bit of a problem so why are
the Democrats losing well we wanted to
talk to you today about the slippery
slope fallacy uh let's put that slippery
slope up there this is what the slippery
slope is there's basically a period of
time and we've been in it now for a
couple years where there's a bunch of
people screaming about things and
they're saying hey there's this Baker
and he doesn't want to be forced to bake
a cake and people call him a bigot and
then they say hey we'd like to chop your
son's genitals off and they say stop
that you transphobe there's the this
period where everyone who is fighting
insanity is treated as if they're
overreacting they're a bigot in a
homophobe and everything else and then
eventually uh as I said earlier the
bottom falls out on these things you end
up with this crash of reality and that's
sort of where I think we are headed
right now so you get this period of as
you can see up top there you're
overreacting and then eventually perhaps
in a midterm election you get so what if
teachers want to have sex and gender
conversations with children in
kindergarten without their parents
knowledge if you oppose it you're
intolerant so this is sort of where
we're at I would say politically right
now and there are many many examples of
it so now we are going to show you some
video from yesterday and this interview
that Joe Biden did is with a biological
male named Dylan Mulvaney Dylan Mulvaney
born a man I suppose transitioned to
female at some point within the last
year so it sounds like a couple hundred
days since Dylan became a woman okay I
don't want to get booted off YouTube
today we're on a nice little run here
but if we do rumble.com Reuben reports
that they're going to be watching out
for all my language here but Dylan is a
biological man Joe Biden sat down with
Dylan who Dylan is now dressing like a
woman
living as a woman or something like that
um and uh Dylan asked and and I don't
even know if Dylan has had all the
surgery like Dylan might have a wang I'm
not sure
what has happened what has happened to
America
um anyway here's Dylan asking Joe Biden
if it's wrong for states to ban gender
surgeries do you think States should
have a right to ban gender affirming
health care I don't think any state or
anybody should have the right to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong
okay it's an incredible response by Joe
Biden now first off I just want to say
as a general rule Joe Biden has been the
perfect presidency for this woke idiocy
because he has no idea what he's doing
he will read whatever they tell him to
read usually very poorly and he stands
for nothing right like so it's just a
matter of push this old buffoon out
there make sure that he doesn't have a
full mental breakdown in front of
everybody and then he'll just say
whatever we want him to say so when
she's can we play the clip one more time
can we play that one more time really
listen to the question and listen to the
answers the question is do the states
have a right to do this do you think
States should have a right to ban gender
affirming health care I don't think any
state or anybody should have the right
to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong
okay well just because you think
something Joe Biden even though you're
the president of the United States
doesn't make it right the states do have
a right we have states rights we have
federalism the states are allowed to
make laws and as for your morality I
don't know where your morality comes
from you often talk about your your
Catholic faith as you're pushing now for
radical eight-month abortions so whether
you're talking legally or morally Joe
you you actually have no handle on what
you're saying now again that person that
Joe was being asked the question by is a
trans woman named Dylan Mulvaney who
just recently transitioned there is a
ton of video of Dylan uh on the interweb
here's a video of Dylan the day before
two days before announcing his or her
visit to the White House it's day 222 of
being a girl I'm in Washington DC and
I'm going to the White House to speak to
the president of the United States I get
to sit down with Joe Biden and now this
news and I get to ask him a few
questions surrounding trans issues in
the United States all are obviously
wondering what I'm gonna wear to meet
the president here you go it's the trans
flag colors
cute right
do you think I just knock on the front
door
let's go I'm not gonna lie I have been
I've been having a rough go of it lately
a lot of darkness and
and today was what I needed to keep
going
um also if you live in the U.S and can
legally vote this is going to be one of
the most important elections of our
lifetimes okay so apparently Dylan was
very depressed and then this call came
just in time it's almost as if some of
this stuff comes with some some mental
health stuff and that perhaps changing
your exterior doesn't solve all of your
interior problems but let's just put
that aside for a moment I was thinking
as I was watching this uh he or she says
that this is day 222 of being a girl I
mean it's just not reality that's just
not real and at some point we just have
to clearly State we cannot play along
with your delusions like we can't I
believe that any adult can live as they
see fit but what I was thinking really
when I was watching that was if you were
a young female journalist let's say you
were a 23 year old female journalist who
went to school studied real hard you've
you interned maybe at a newspaper you
started your own operation whatever it
might be and then you want to interview
the president about some serious issues
and then you're upstaged by the dude who
may or may not have a penis dressed as a
woman who is now at the White House I am
not saying this is not transphobia I
don't have an irrational fear of trans
people I do have I would say a rational
fear of made up nonsense because I
believe that I live in the real world as
do most of you and these people are just
dragging us into this insanity and then
you get answers from the president of
the United States that are are even
worse than the question itself right Joe
Biden's answer to that was absolutely
insane
um here's a little bit more this is a
couple weeks ago uh Dylan Mulvaney now
what you just saw was day 222 so I think
this is day this is day hundred
something a little more from Dylan
mulmaney sick being a girl and today I'm
in nature
trees I love them
water lakes I love them
heels they're my hiking heels I love
them
Bridges love them
coconut water love it not mad just love
it
wind turbine love it Luke Meadows love
them
[Music]
I'm scared of getting Lyme disease
love ya
oh
did you see that I gotta get out of here
I don't really know what's going on here
all I know is that person just
interviewed the president at the White
House is that person just a troll like
is any of this real I've seen those
videos over the last couple weeks this
person's been popping up you know
suddenly they just the algorithms just
push people to you because we're all
being manipulated in crazy ways so I've
seen these videos before and I thought
they were a joke like I was like this
cannot possibly be real so I do think
it's possible that Dylan uh is just a
troll but somehow whether whether Dylan
is either mentally ill or a troll either
way he or she got to the White House and
got to ask Joe Biden that question and
Joe Biden said that as a moral and legal
matter uh no one should be able to stop
people from transitioning stop young
people in essence from transitioning
that's really what this is all about uh
but the woke nonsense let's get back to
that slippery slope thing right it's a
dumb PR move by Biden who who is in
charge that that two weeks from the
election thought okay whether Dylan
Mulvaney is actually trans or not or
whether she or he is a troll or not or
whatever that that would be the thing
that Joe Biden should be doing Joe Biden
should be sitting down with her him
talking about these things as opposed to
any of the issues that we really care
about I mean it's just so incredible
it's actually actually completely
incredible
um but uh you do know that Joe Biden
does want the government to be able to
tax the hell out of you to make sure
that his political agenda is taken care
of he even says it himself do you
support a federal fund for individuals
like myself who need to take time off
work obtain Child Care the answer is
absolutely but guess what we need the
same votes we need to overrule that to
reinstate
the uh the decision that was struck down
by the court
I mean I do support that and I've urged
publicly urge companies to do that I've
urged them publicly as president of the
United States saying this is what you
should be doing I urge you to do it
sorry Joe companies have free speech and
free association and just because you
urge companies to do what what you want
with their money and treat their
employees as you wish that's not how it
works there is a word Connor can you
help me with this one or maybe Phoenix
you could chime in on this and there's a
word it starts with an F that people say
a lot it's clipping my mind at the
moment when governments and private
corporations work together to oppress
the people for political purposes Schism
fascism right thank you
um that so it's like who are the
fascists they're calling us fascists
he's telling you this and by the way
when he's telling you hey I would like
to pressure corporations to do what I
wish related to health care what health
care policies they have health care if
you want to call abortion Health Care
um you should take him at his word that
he would love to pressure companies to
do that because this is the same old win
bag who was pushing for companies to
fire employees when they didn't want to
be injected with the experimental
vaccination that basically does not work
work right so you should be a little
concerned about this uh this combination
of state and corporate power because
again fascism bad not the way they use
the word but the way the word really is
designed uh here's Biden being very
confused about what's going on with guns
my my legislation says there can be no
more than eight bullets in a round okay
no more than eight bullets in a round
I'm actually not a gun expert although
we did go shooting in Homestead a couple
weeks ago
um a bullet is around you have a
magazine or a clip that has many of them
but ah you got it all right he just
doesn't know what he's saying he doesn't
know what he's saying uh here he is
completely making up something that did
not happen related to student loan debt
secondly if you don't have one of those
loans you just get 10 000 written off
it's passed I got it passed by a vote or
two
yeah I never meant to vote it was never
voted on so he just completely made that
up but let's move on from Old Joe Biden
there must be other some there must be
some sane Democrats out there to counter
this right I mean my God for God's sakes
uh here's Nancy Pelosi but on things
like sending you know those fourteen
hundred dollar checks putting cash out
there I mean didn't that end up
contributing to inflation do you have
any regrets about the bills you passed
and how you structured them no
absolutely not because this that was
necessary for people to survive our
purpose this was that it was
inflationary the Wonder but the point is
is that when you reduce unemployment
it's inflationary that is a fact
all right first off she's starting to
look like Michael Jackson in the later
years that's just the thing I don't
again I don't know why all the Democrats
start looking so insane I don't know why
my theory on it would be something like
this you know Jordan Peterson often
talks about how when you're lying all
the time your face actually starts to
show it the misery you can see it on
people there's a certain misery you can
see sort of the the what the end result
of the Endless dishonesty is and I think
these people are so dishonest they're so
it's it's just such Evil Within them at
this point that the facelifts and
everything else is to combat that but
then it just it's it's sort of the
physiology versus the the chemicals and
I don't know what's going on anyway she
looks like Michael Jackson
um yes lady if you give all these people
fourteen hundred dollars and you're not
giving it to them because it's their
money in the first place and you keep
spending all this money so money has
less value than the money that you're
giving back to the people who you stole
it from isn't going to really help the
economy or help the people but this is
what they do they put 10 they're nice
while you're voting for them to control
you please govern me harder please I
vote for you to take my money and then
give it back to me and smack me on the
button send me on my way but man this is
all good you should be feeling good
about today's show because the point is
no one is buying this nonsense nobody is
buying this nonsense and again the polls
are bearing it out but suddenly as I
showed you before Joe Biden doesn't
believe in polls and I don't think Nancy
Pelosi believes in polls and here's a
little more with Pelosi on what's going
on with inflation and the fact is is
that uh when I hear people talk about
inflation as I heard them there we have
to change that subject inflation is a
global phenomena phenomenon the EU the
European Union the UK the British have
higher inflation rate than we do here
it's not the fight is not about
inflation it's about the cost of living
oh it's not about inflation it's just
about the cost of living nothing they
say has any meaning it doesn't mean
anything guess what when inflation is
high the cost of living goes up right
when inflation is high and your money is
less valuable then you have to spend
more money to get the same things
whether it's your rent or to buy a car
or to buy some chicken thighs like that
is how it works but I like that at least
at the beginning she was somewhat honest
like we got to change the topic they're
talking about inflation could somebody
talk about my eyebrows you see what I
just did here I mean this is serious
stuff uh but again she just simply does
not believe that people don't like
Democrat policies and that it's coming
out in the polling why why don't the
American people according to the surveys
trust Democrats but instead trust
Republicans
well let me just say one of the you
talked about what you perceive to be a
change in momentum let me just tell you
what I have seen over this past month I
don't subscribe to what you said that
they don't trust us
let me just a thing
I don't
my face is falling off I got the
commercial
I mean Jesus Christ so okay so they
don't believe in the polls well keep not
believing in the polls lady keep going I
mean I really want you guys to keep
going with it you know like keep going
with all your bad keep going chopping
off genitals no states rights high taxes
crashing the economy Warren you keep
going keep going and we're going to show
you uh in about two weeks where where
we're all at with the rest of this but
what do they need as I always tell you
because we've got about 10 days left
what do they need to maintain power they
need fear and they must spread fear more
than Megatron's Skeletor and Cobra
Commander combined because what will
happen if the Republicans take over
and game okay destruction of the economy
Republican leadership in congress has
made it clear
they will crash the economy next year by
threatening the full faith and credit of
the United States for the first time in
our history putting the United States
into fall unless unless we yield to
their demand to cut Social Security
Medicare
first off they do this every this is
what they do every two years Republicans
are cutting Social Security and Medicare
this is they do this is like the number
one fear tactic because they know that
older people who older people who vote
because older people do vote in higher
numbers they start freaking out about it
it never ends up happening that the
Republicans will crash the economy uh
Dems you don't need the Republicans
because you're doing it pretty well on
yourselves remember you are in charge
right now and the economy is crashing
the idea that maybe the Republicans who
are not very good at any of this either
but as I always say you don't have to be
a republican but you cannot be a
Democrat but it's not like the
Republicans are so great but imagine if
imagine if in two weeks the house flips
right so then we have everyone's sworn
in a little bit after that and imagine
the house flips the Senate flips and
there's like a cultural flip like
everyone is like oh the woke stuff no
more the endless spending no more the
war no more like imagine if we actually
flipped it do you think the economy
would crash I actually think that the
evil corporations that Bernie Sanders
was talking about earlier the
corporations might start figuring out
ways to do business properly again I
think that NASDAQ and the s p all these
things business might start flourishing
again people would not be afraid that a
bunch of backwards woke buffoons were
running the economy and then there would
be confidence again what you need in a
country that's doing things well is
confidence you need a ramrod to stand up
straight and get out there and feel good
so when you feel good other people feel
good you start exchanging goods and
services again and voila you gotta you
chug an economy uh here is Kamala Harris
she's a liar when it comes to just about
everything although in her defense she
doesn't know what she's saying either uh
here she is saying and this is a
complete lie and we've got the evidence
uh that she had nothing to do with the
Minnesota Freedom fund during the BLM
riots this was the group that was uh
paying for people to get out of jail
they were paying the bail on people who
were burning down buildings breaking uh
into stores General chaos etc etc I want
to ask you uh the Minnesota GOP is
holding a press conference this
afternoon to criticize you for your
support a couple of years ago before you
were the vice president or something
called the Minnesota Freedom fund that
was really set up to help those who were
arrested after in the aftermath of the
George Floyd riots help them get out
it's since been sort of morphed into
something else and has been used to help
people get out who've been accused of
many other crimes do you have any
thoughts about this I think that
unfortunately what we're seeing is
people are playing political games right
now we're 18 days away from midterms and
we have sadly not seen a lack of
misinformation and disinformation and
and I think this is another one of those
examples
political games
misinformation surely we can't find a
tweet of Kamala Harris supporting the
Minnesota Freedom fun we don't have that
what our diggity dog if you're able to
chip in now to the Minnesota Freedom
fund to help post bail for those
protesting on the ground in Minnesota
yes it's right there lady reality is
misinformation if you are a chronic liar
and that's what she is oh and as long as
we're in Minnesota here's Minnesota
Attorney General Keith Ellison he's a
bad dude he doesn't know anybody that
wants to defund the police and then I
don't know anybody who thinks that we
should defund the police
oh really Keith because here you are
with two ladies yep there you are uh
Keith Ellison two days ago with Corey
Bush you know we've played the videos of
her defund the police and ilhan Omar who
wants to dismantle the police uh two of
the leading voices in the defund the
police movement so everything they say
is a lie they have gone so all in on
lies two plus two does not equal four
having male genitalia doesn't make you a
dude the rest of it
everything they say is alive so they
must keep lying but what else can they
do they have to keep scaring the hell
out of you right so now do we have the
the warning we have the warning because
we're going to show Joey Reed I think we
got the warning yeah here's Joy Reid on
the televised mental institution known
as MSNBC Florida's Jim Crow Redux
Governor Ron DeSantis even has his own
office of election crimes newly released
and frankly disturbing video shows Tampa
Police back in August arresting people
on charges of illegal voting in the 2020
election that is because Ron DeSantis
and his Republican cronies in the state
legislature have done everything in
their power to reverse the clock back to
the 19th century
yeah it's it's just it's prediction it's
a fictitious Network everything they say
is fiction by the way you know we're in
a day of an age of cultural
appropriation aren't we
she has blonde hair
generally speaking uh as far as I know
black people tend not to have blonde
hair it's just that's just a thing it's
just a thing so she's appropriating the
[ __ ] out of Suzanne Summers and I don't
like it you guys get the Suzanne Summers
reference come on tell me that worked
for you
you got it Three's Company man Suzanne
Summers no oh youth is wasted on the
young
that's messed up uh anyway she's she's
just ridiculous everyone can vote here
in Florida you do have to have an ID to
vote you can get an ID very easily and
the idea that there's an office there is
an office they do have an office to make
sure that people who are voting are
supposed to vote and people who aren't
supposed to vote don't vote there is an
office for that here Joy okay yeah just
like in the Jim Crow South ridiculous
and that that he doesn't want black
people to vote I know several black
people who are voting for Ron DeSantis
but if you want to see how stupid
everything is this this might be the
most everything's the most insane thing
so I don't want to be too hyperbolic
here is a tweet by a quote-unquote
journalist his name is Alec Mcgill and
he uh was quoting uh Financial Times
article this might be look at this this
is so bananas so they just want to get
to Santa's right according to a friend
DeSantis would tell dates that he liked
Thai food but pronounced it thigh if
they corrected him Finch wrote he would
find an excuse to leave he'd didn't want
a girlfriend who corrected him according
to quote-unquote journalist Joshua
Chafin
oh my God
oh my God
you know what I'm going to the debate
tonight
and I if I get a moment with Ron
DeSantis first off I'm going to bring
I'm going to bring some Pad Thai I'm
going to bring some chicken Pad Thai and
I'm going to take it and I'm gonna smash
it in his face because he's a racist
it's so stupid I'm being told right now
live on the Fly that that guy just
deleted that tweet right before our show
started however the quote is in the
article Financial Times felt it was
important to go back 20 years 25 years
ago roughly to Ron desantis's college
life to find out how he pronounced the
word Thai
right righto let's continue with
journalism uh here's a guy that works at
CNN he's a journalist named Ryan struck
uh and he tweeted out an incredible
resource and this is by another guy this
Dale guy D Dale eight he's another
quote-unquote journalist uh an
incredible resource from Dale on
Election deniers at least 22 of 36
Republican candidates from Governor are
election deniers at least 19 of 35
Republican candidates for US Senate are
election donors and at least 11 of 27
Republican candidates for secretaries
eight are elections
oddly uh as far as I know he didn't
check any of the Democrats on that
because Hillary Clinton election denier
Stacy Abrams election denier the list
goes on and on Election denier
illegitimate president Russia hoax etc
etc but this is what they got it's all
that's left because after you chop off
everybody's genitals all you got left is
election denial uh but this is it this
this is what they're campaigning on and
the mainstream media
is trying to perhaps catch up a little
bit this is one of the things I'm always
fascinated with when the people who get
everything wrong or ignore the stories
then reality just kind of keeps on
coming right so they miss all of the
stuff when it happens and then reality
keeps coming and then they flip right in
front of your eyes and you're like oh
they're not so bad but you must remember
that they are here is a video of Jake
Tapper again he's a he's a Democrat
that's okay Jake you should just say it
he's a Democrat and he's shocked that
we're not having a national conversation
about the Damage Done to kids from
closing schools but I'm going to just
give you the lead right now uh we've all
been having that conversation what he
means is he's not having the
conversation videotape I have to say I'm
surprised that there hasn't been
a national
conversation about the Damage Done to
kids because of these school closures
and the virtual learning and everything
because I mean I'm not saying there
should be a national do-over but we
can't just pretend that fifth graders
who are now seventh graders
that that didn't happen you know like I
feel like there should be and not not
with a Blame Game look it happened
people did it it was criticized the
school closures the virtual learning Etc
but here we are
um
there needs to be like like a bipartisan
movement you know Jake is shocked Jake
is shocked that there wasn't a national
conversation about this well Jake we
were all talking about it everyone
online that is doing your job better
than you with way less resources uh was
doing this we were all talking about how
kids should be at school how masks don't
work how forcing Jabs doesn't work how
this is going to cause all of these
problems that we now know whether it's
delayed speech in young children or
myocarditis in you know T young male
teenagers like we were all talking about
it where were you so he's saying well we
don't want to play the blame game but
dude mirror get one right come on now
come on now but what's interesting is so
now it's finally bubbling forward and
there he is I mean he has Jeb Bush on
like talk about completely irrelevant
you have a completely irrelevant guest
who has no clout within either political
party to come on and talk about how you
didn't do your job properly something
like that but people are seeing it
people really are seeing it and do you
know why that's good because crazy
things can happen I do not think it is
completely off the table that Republican
Lee zeldin is going to win in New York
and he's gaining a lot of momentum the
polls are basically showing them neck
and neck and again it's worth repeating
nobody has voted for Kathy hochel she
was installed this woman has no support
she's got the Nancy Pelosi eyebrow thing
but that's all she's got here's a little
bit from Lee zeldon now if Kathy hokel
had accepted your invite for debate
she'll sing next to me it would be a
fair question to ask her why do you
think that New York is leading the
entire nation in population loss now she
couldn't finish that sentence I would
say that the reason why New York leads
the entire nation population losses
because they're hitting their Breaking
Point okay and they feel like their
wallet their safety their freedom the
quality of their kids education are
under attack and they're looking at
other states so you have to look at the
economic burden and part of that too is
bring down energy costs reversing the
state's ban on the safe extraction of
natural gas approving new pipeline
applications there up in Albany as far
as the business climate goes stop
picking winners and losers with these
tax breaks i instead level the playing
field
happy Ultra has repeatedly referred to
Lee zeldin who is a moderate Democrat
like if you're looking at that guy or
listening to that guy and you're like
he's an extremist racist Republican like
the problem's on you she is repeatedly
referred to him as a Maga extremist she
is also told on more than one occasion
half of the population because you know
states are basically 50 50 even if they
vote 55-45 but you know Most states are
roughly 50 50. she told Republicans that
live in her state to leave because they
don't share her values New York has had
a Breaking Point it might happen maybe
people are sick of the high taxes maybe
people are sick of the Endless
corruption maybe people are sick of
being you know at the whim of a
politician whether you're going to get
out of your house or not or everything
else like it's really it's really it's
there's a chance there's a chance and so
you're saying there's a chance right
like that's that's where we're at right
now anyway I showed you a lot of
Democrats today we didn't show you a lot
on Republicans showed you a lot of
Democrats I thought I'd show you a
Republican to end this thing who was
quite popular in his day and had a sense
of what government is and isn't supposed
to do and really what the spirit of
America is all about and it's uh I would
say connected to the idea that perhaps
all of you watching this should be
telling all of your friends hey you want
to get out of this thing well maybe we
have to vote for Republicans right now
no government ever voluntarily reduces
itself in size so government programs
once launched never disappeared actually
a government Bureau is the nearest thing
to eternal life we'll ever see on this
Earth
[Music]
[Applause]
he almost single-handedly resurrected
and redefined the modern conservative
movement but he did much more than that
he resurrected and redefined America
known by friend and foe alike as the
great communicator even Democrats
conceded that no one could connect with
the American people like Reagan whenever
he went on TV which was often to promote
a policy he invariably swung the
American people his way when he
explained something it just made sense
I like that end part when he explained
something it just makes sense does that
remind you of anybody maybe a guy here
in Florida who's just saying the basic
truth trying to get the government off
your back caring about freedom and
letting people live as they see fit or
as Joy Reid puts it you know the fascist
in charge or something like that I mean
these people are nuts but that's all we
have to get back to guys like it isn't
like this huge swing we have to end the
woke thing and then just get back to an
America that was say about 20 years ago
and then there you know there were a few
things that we still had to fix and
we've pretty much done it
um I think we can do it I really do
think we can do it so even though I
showed you a lot of nonsensical Democrat
stuff today you you should be feeling
good about the trend right now you
should be feeling good about the trend
because it is trending in our Direction
and that means you got to vote you got
to encourage other people to vote if you
have friends on the fence you got to try
to explain this stuff to them properly
you gotta drag your beaten up old
Republican friend in New York who's
depressed about everything and doesn't
believe anything can change you got to
get them out there to vote if you're
here in Florida even though DeSantis is
probably going to win this thing by 10
points like let's get him to win by 15
points like just there should be a
message sent to these people no more of
your nonsense and then as I keep saying
we will look in that rear view mirror
and say AO see you later that will be it
that will be it for these people guys
it's me Monday over at the
reubenreport.locals.com community here's
the one that I put up this morning I
like this one uh moms before asking what
their kids are reading in school that's
of course from Greece and moms after
finding out what's in their kids school
library obviously from Terminator and
plenty of other people are putting some
funny stuff up in there you can join us
at reubenreport.locals.com we got a cold
close for you in just a moment just a
couple comments real quick EK says New
York is pretty corrupt but I really hope
zeldin can take it look if we're to
believe that any of these systems work
then if enough people have just been fed
up like really imagine
would it be like if New York by the way
New York had you know we think of New
York as this blue stalwart it eternally
blue state New York had George Pataki
who I was at least two terms
um so and that wasn't that long ago
right that was I don't know 15 20 years
ago so it is possible it really is
possible but imagine if if New York goes
red and then freaking Whitmer is out in
Michigan Whitmer who has just been one
of the worst of the worst
and then they will just throw Biden up
to be that lame duck and we can just
move on like it's possible guys Amy says
I like that Democrat defense on the
inflation topic is that globally we're
all screwed oh good I feel so much
better I should have mentioned that
earlier right because that's their new
thing is like no no no no no it's not us
that is just us that are screwed it's
everybody so please vote for us it still
makes no sense on its own right like it
just on its own on its face it makes no
sense uh and talway says Nancy is
looking more like Freddy these days I
assume you mean Freddy Krueger yeah
she's got a little Freddy Krueger thing
but I'm thinking it's more of a Michael
Jackson thing you know like Michael
Jackson in the later years puffy shirt
face pulled back and and remember when
it comes to Michael Jackson only when
people doubt America
only in America could a young black boy
grow up to be an old white woman the
Michael Jackson story
if you're not subscribed rumble.com
Ruben report play along in live chat and
get Early Access and add free stuff and
all that Ruben report.locals.com my full
interview with Miami mayor Francis
Suarez is up right now
and we leave you on this Monday with the
elderly man pretending to be president
and quick reminder that I will be at the
Florida gubernatorial debate tonight so
I'm going to try to do some live
streaming from there if possible if not
I'll take some videos and we'll uh we'll
make them part of the show tomorrow have
a great Monday everybody
this ain't your father's Republican
Party
not not a joke
this is not your father's Republican
Party
this is not your father's Republican
Party
this is a different deal
they are not
they are not
Who We Are
they're not who America is because this
is not your father's Republican party
this I call them the new Republican
party this is not your father's
Republican party I remember
working with Republicans
Republicans
and by the way this ain't your father's
Republican Party
this is not your father's Republican
Party
this is a different group of folks
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
like a republican not every
pedicle right in the Republican Party
[Music]